[Music]
Avengers infinity war is six days away
or five if you're catching it the day
before like I am and Marvel has been
super generous with us the past few
weeks giving us new TV spot ads for
Avengers infinity war almost every other
day and given us actual clips from the
movie through channels such as Good
Morning America and my past few
breakdown videos of the trailers I asked
you guys to leave in the comment section
what you guys think of these trailers if
you think they're too much or if they
get you even more excited to see the
movie
I myself have said oh jeez another
trailer multiple times in the past few
weeks but having said that I actually
get more excited when I see these sneak
peeks of the scenes from the movie and
when I see new trailers come out judging
by your comments it seems like half of
you feel the same way that I do and half
who you think that there are two
spoilers but let's ask the question why
is Marvel giving us so much about the
movie right before it comes out but
first please subscribe to my channel if
you want to stay up to date on Avengers
infinity war and all things Marvel so
first and foremost they're obviously
doing it to get the word out about the
movie so people get really excited and
go see it which they've been super
successful at but if you look past that
and you look at the core of what they
seem to be doing and you look at things
such as interviews that Kevin Feige is
done and interviews that the Russo
brothers have done it clearly seems like
what they're doing is misdirection I
think the biggest attempt at
misdirection was from the new clip that
was released the other night that had
Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive
fighting Black Widow Falcon and Captain
America there is no way that Black Widow
and Falcon can take on anyone in the
black order and Liv and Proxima midnight
or Corvus glaive could take on Captain
America one on one and still most likely
beat him so Scarlet Witch and Falcon
taking on Proxima midnight in Corvus
glaive and hand-to-hand combat and
beating them
uh-uh no way Proxima midnight took on
Thor by herself and defeated him and
Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive both
defeated the Hulk so you're telling me
that they can't take on little black
widow and Falcon there's just no way and
Kevin Feige and the Russo brothers they
know this and they've stated in an
interview that they really do
listen to the fans they listen to what
they have to say a good example is they
listen when the fans told them that our
favorite villains disappeared too soon
with the exception of Loki Ultron was a
huge villain in the comics and he
disappeared after one movie the Russo
brothers have stated that they know this
they acknowledge what we're saying and
there's no way that they're gonna make
the black order just some flimsy little
gang of Thanos tugs that can be defeated
by Black Widow and Falcon and they've
also come out and stated that fans have
no idea what the actual plot of Avengers
infinity war is and they don't want us
to know they want us to go in and be hit
with the best movie of all time and
they're not going to do that by giving
away the movie and trailers these
trailers and new clips are to get us
excited to get us pumped and to get
everybody interested and talking about
it and then once we get in the movie and
watch it our minds are gonna be blown
because it's gonna go a completely
different direction than what we all
thought it would be these are just my
personal feelings on this I think that
Kevin Feige and the Russo brothers are
way too smart to be given everything
away in the trailers like everyone
thinks that they've been doing I think
they're trying to make the fans think
the movies about something and then BOOM
and it was something completely
different in the movie which would just
be honestly be awesome but again this is
just my personal opinion what do you
guys think do you think the trailers
give us a actual glump of what's inside
infinity war or do you think that the
Russo brothers are just being very
clever and tricky with them let's talk
about it in the comments below I'd love
to hear your thoughts hit the thumbs up
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to my channel to join the
Wolfpack and stay up to date on Avengers
infinity war Marvel and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right yet to fail all the same